minsk belarus
a friday morning in september
in europe's last dictatorship this is
rapidly becoming the new normal
[Music]
sometimes there's no time for laws and
tough measures must be taken to stop
all the trash from rising up
[Applause]
this peaceful protest movement and the
state's brutal response
is complicated to cover
journalists have been arrested stripped
of their accreditations
ours was never granted in the first
place so we filmed this in a secret
location
this man was detained shortly after the
election threatened with rape and beaten
repeatedly
they commanded us to look into the
ground
hands behind our backs and run
between two rows of
enforcers in black robes and helmets
with rubber sticks and
[Music]
they were beating us
in the legs arms on our
backs fear has taken the wind out of the
factory strikes
[Applause]
this was the early days the
post-election hubris
when president lukashenko was geared off
stage by workers who traditionally
formed his support base
is on the strike committee at the minsk
tractor factory
she says the kgb have moles there people
are scared
the bosses threaten to fire us in fact
some people have already been fired
in a very brutal way and when they saw
this happening they began to think
we live in a dormitory we've got bank
loans how are we going to live
we can't continue to be on strike we'll
get fired
she was detained briefly last sunday but
she still plans to go out this weekend
the fifth weekend of protests in a week
where security forces picked off
opposition leaders one by one
bundling maria kolesnikova into the back
of this van
raiding her offices and driving her to
the ukrainian border with a sack over
her head she says
telling her that she would be leaving
the country dead or alive
so she ripped up her passport making
father and country proud
will meet his russian counterpart on
monday in the resort town of sochi
vladimir putin seemingly willing to prop
him up for now
but lock up the leaders and the protests
continue
because so many refused to stand down
outraged at the brutality
demanding the release of detainees
determined that their president must go
down in magnesium moscow